2 mais la politique vous restez avec
nous il est 18h15 ce lundi politique
gaël le dantec examen de la réforme de
la constitution française va commencer
demain en commission à l'assemblée
nationale avant d'être soumis aux
parlementaires à dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent on saura alors si
la réunion conservera son exception ou
deviendra un département d'outre-mer
comme les autres notre invité n'est plus
parlementaire mais bataille en première
ligne sur le sujet il bataille aussi le
pouvoir parisien pour faire avancer sa
vision de l'avenir de la réunion en
cadre des assises d outre-mer mbira ce
qu'ils attendent du livre bleu que la
ministre doit remettre bientôt président
il a perdu une bataille mais b sera-t-il
des bras dans le dossier la gestion des
déchets dans le nord et l'est de l'île
nous parlerons également de la carrière
de dioré de la droite qui n'en finit
plus de se déchirer de l'europe si nous
en avons le temps car notre invité est
plutôt du genre bavard jean paul
virapoullé maire de saint-andré
président de la cirest conseil régional
est l'invité de lundi politique sur la
première une émission que vous pouvez
suivre en vidéo sur notre site internet
jean paul virapoullé bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur d'intec merci d'avoir accepté
dans l'actualité avant d'aborder les
thèmes que j'indiquais d'abord ce drame
qui s'est déroulé dans votre commune
hier un homme est entre la vie et la
mort après avoir reçu un coup de fusil
pour semble-t-il un conflit de voisinage
gré l'autre deux familles est ce que
vous confirmez que le suspect bien
employé communal et qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire ce soir sur cette affaire il ya
1400 36 employés communaux c'est pas le
fait qu'il soit employé communal qui est
la cause du drame la raison c'est un
drame de voisinage
mais ce qui est plus grave d'après ce
qu'on me dit c'est lorsque le blessé
était par terre il ya eu acharnement à
coups de crosse de fusil
s'ils avaient eu la balle comme elle n'a
pas une porte et meurtrière probablement
le blessé aurait récupéré
moi j'ai un message pour les réunionnais
tous les week-ends je me pose la
question de savoir combien permis
conduire on vend lui et combien de
femmes - deux battus
combien de personnes vont être massacrés
combien de litres d'alcool on à boire et
combien de drames
on va vivre il faut changer de braquet
la réunion est une terre bénie des dieux
dans le bassin tu chutes 2/5 sommes
situés
c'est probablement la seule région où on
peut connaissances sur ce sol
à voir tous les moyens de l'état de
l'europe de la région du département des
communes pour se promouvoir maîtriser
son avenir et vivre heureux pourquoi ce
gaspillage d'argent dans l'alcool
pourquoi cette violence vous avez une
idée de la réponse je cherche la réponse
parce que je suis un homme de terrain un
homme de coeur nous avons une grosse
politique de la ville le fait d'être élu
depuis 50 ans montrent que 40 20 me
donne une expérience je n'ai jamais
connu ça avant je pense que les films
que l'on passe sur les médias des films
de violence comme moi même à 74 ans je
peux pas regarder ça doit avoir une
influence sur le comportement des gens
que cette politique dépravé de publicité
où on utilise le corps des êtres humains
pour vendre des produits manufacturés
c'est pas une conception noble de
l'homme du respect de sa dignité
mais je crois qu'on est dans une société
mercantile de violence qui aboutit à ces
drames il ya moyen quand on est élu de
faire quelque chose pour que ça n'arrive
pas que ça arrive - oui la politique de
la ville est un grand moyen même
travaillant sur fayat nous travaillons
sur le centre-ville pour dialoguer mais
aussi une chose vous avez signé la
semaine dernière avec la pole ici avec
l'état un protocole d'accord pour
associer les citoyens à la sécurité de
leur quartier ne peut pas faire évoluer
le dantec des êtres humains par
correspondance
il faut dialoguer faut être en face
d'eux il faut connaître leur naissance
leur drame la famille monoparentale
l'alcoolisme la violence intrafamiliale
l'échec scolaire parfois le manque de
revenus tout ça s'ajoute ans ça fait des
gens malheureux mais je le redis
et c'est pour ça que vous m'avez invité
le 18 juin cela lance un appel il n'y a
pas de situation difficile de laquelle
on ne puisse pas s'en sortir
moi je vous tends la main pareillement
les élus nous tendons la main et
saisissez tout ce qu'on va mettre en
place aux indiens mot la région et la
boue et la haye le département vont
s'allier pour mettre des prépas pour les
bâches et qui sont en train de passer
leur bac du rhin des bâches et fort il y
aura des matchs est faible il ya les
prépas pour l'effort il n'y a pas de
prépa pour les faibles
mais nous allons mettre dans les mois
qui viennent une préparation pour que
les bâches et qui ont eu le bac mais
qu'ils sont désorientés 65% d'entre eux
échouent à l'université st drame social
il faut arrêter ce drame social et
mettre en place sur un an deux ans trois
ans et nous allons pouvoir à la région
et au département
un parcours de qualification qui amène
les un nouvel épanouissement
l'échec est chose de violence la
réussite est source de réconciliation la
misère la violence ne date pas d'hier la
réunion non mais là tu un niveau qu'elle
n'avait pas bon moi je connais la
réunion une à 69 lorsque j'étais élu
mais l'association venu on est d'accord
que il ya eu de la misère mais elle
existe encore beaucoup vous le disiez il
ya beaucoup de gens trouvaient deux
jeunes qui sont en échec scolaire il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont au chômage
mais il ya des situations familiales et
des problèmes de revenus
vous disiez vous êtes élu depuis depuis
48 ans on envie de dire mais qu'est ce
qui n'a pas marché qu'est ce que n'avait
pas fait non nous répondre est-ce que
vous avez vu le chemin parcouru on a mis
la bosse pour les grandes écoles pour
les enfants passaient le seul
département français qu'il a fait nous
formons pour chaque année au moins 800
gènes dans les grandes écoles
aujourd'hui nous avons la réunion il va
y avoir plusieurs milliers de bacheliers
la réunion forme une élite la réunion
les gens regardaient le cyclone qui a
down on l'appelle pratiquement
berger parce que les gens étaient logés
correctement regardez les soins nous
sommes la seule région dans le bassin
sud océan indien où que vous soyez riche
ou pas vous avez votre carte vitale vous
êtes soigné dans les meilleures
conditions dans une clinique privée ou
d'un hôpital
nous sommes ici dans une situation où il
ya des progrès immenses et je voudrais
rendre hommage à michel debré en passant
pour pour que la réunion soit ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
mais ça ne suffit pas parce que les
problèmes d'hier ont une des solutions
d'hyères les problèmes d'aujourd'hui
doit avoir des solutions d'aujourd'hui
et nous devons nous projeter dans
l'avenir c'est pour ça que nous avons
des projets ambitieux pour la réunion je
voudrais qu'on reviendra rapidement pour
terminer sur ce chapitre de la sécurité
à saint-andré sur ce protocole signé
pour associer les citoyens la sécurité
l'idée c'est quoi c'est créer des
milices ou au contraire d'éviter que les
citoyens ne créent eux-mêmes cela-dit
matinée 10 lamely c'est rajouter de la
violence à la violence
le protocole avec la police et le
commandant du but qu'il nous
nouvellement arrivé et tout le corps de
police a mené la police de quartier pour
faire camarades avec les gens causes
exactes nous ne sommes pas là pour taper
dessus et nous sommes pas là pour
réprimer nous sommes là pour vivre
ensemble et lorsque les gens connaîtront
ce que demandent les gens c'est qu'il ya
plus de cambriolage chez eux
oui mais quand on aura éduquer l'écran
brisé des cambrioleurs pour un moins de
cambriolages par la force uniquement
il faut la force il faut la répression
il faut les tribunaux il faut les juges
mais si on peu avant prévenir le mal
c'est mieux en fait les deux répression
et prévention
jean paul virapoullé la réforme de la
constitution vont commencer à être
examiné demain en commission à
l'assemblée nationale avant d'être
présenté aux parlementaires ça devrait
être au mois de juillet pour la première
partie et puis ensuite les préfets
ensuite au mois d'août et puis voilà
voter probablement l'année prochaine
vous tenez absolument à ce que votre
amendement celui qu'on appelle l'
amendement virapoullé saillir l'alinéa 5
de l'actuel article 73 votée en 2003 où
vous souhaitez absolument qu'il soit
conservé cet alinéa l'on va rappeler un
peu rapidement il dit que contrairement
aux autres départements ultramarins la
réunion n'est pas autorisée à adapter
les lois et règlements qui dépendent pas
des compétences de la région du
département c'est simple adaptée
localement localement je vous pose une
autre question
vous aimez la réunion 21
luis yanez guadeloupe aujourd'hui nous
sommes cités en exemple dans toutes les
sphères européennes et de gouvernement
comme étant la région et la collectivité
départementale la mieux gérée
je vous repose une autre question est ce
que vous savez qu'en martinique
ils ont des crédits européens comme nous
mais comme ils ont fait l'assemblée
unique qu'on empêche que mon amendement
empêche et parce qu'ils ont mis en place
la loi p qui ne fonctionne plus depuis
2013 monsieur le dantec l'échec de leur
pays était telle qu'il n'y a plus aucune
région qui sont nos petits qui sont très
occupés mais au moment où je vous parle
je viens sortait d'une réunion avec le
président de région mes collègues la
majorité nous allons présenter un compte
administratif dans deux jours et il est
excédentaire et les en bonne santé
dans le même temps monsieur le président
de région marie jeanne a déclaré à la
presse vous avez d'articles dont je vous
le dis de mémoire je ne peux pas
apporter ma part de crédit politique
pour nous pour mettre en place ces
crédits européens
en gros l'europe donnent 70 ai dit vous
mettez 30 sur la table et bien la région
martinique tu peux faire mettre ses 30
passes que l'assemblée unique a ruiné la
martinique
je trouve ça pour la réunion nous sommes
le moule le département la région la
mieux gérée par ailleurs par ailleurs vu
la qualité de gestion des ports pas
forcément c'est de l'assemblée unique a
ruiné la martinique a foutu en l'air
la guyane et nous sommes le seul
département région qui fonctionne bien
par ailleurs la région s'occupe de
l'économie le département s'occupe du
social regrouper les deux ans en sait
mettre le poumon économique avec le
poumon social ça fait qu'on circuit par
tous existe et troisièmement vous avez
vous vu et pas de la fusion région
département nantes c'est maintenant par
ailleurs et puis ça ne fonctionne pas la
fsa a été fait par ailleurs je vous ai
parlé ici de l'art et mayotte
80% des règlements français des lois
françaises résulte de l'adaptation du
droit communautaire
dire qu'on ne peut pas adapter à code
avant de m'en virapoulle est à double
non sens
d'abord parce que sur le plan européen
on peut le faire et par ailleurs il est
récompensé dans l'ordre d'après la
dernière mouture
de la révision présentée en conseil des
ministres cette exception que vous avez
défendu et obtenu en 2003 devrait rester
si on relit le texte le texte
gouvernemental l'a maintenue voilà pour
l'instant il est maintenu la pression
vonn débat et en même temps on a le
sentiment quand même que que la posture
que vous défendez est en contradiction
avec le discours ambiant sur l'autonomie
sur le droit la différenciation sur la
prise en compte des spécificités des
spécificités locales
est ce que est ce que c'est bien
nécessaire aujourd'hui en 2002 18 de
s'accrocher à cette ascendance
d'exception réunionnais je m'accroche à
rien michel debré a rédigé la
constitution de la vème république pour
moi qui le rédige et celui commis
l'amendement c'est la ligne à ce qu'ils
attendaient c'est lui qui m'a appris la
constitution et c'est lui qui m'a dit
jean-paul vous veillerez et je parle on
savoure noir lé donc chaque mois son
importance vous veillerez jean-paul
comme la prunelle de vos yeux à l'unité
de législation avec la france et à
l'application circonstancié de la loi
c'est fort ce que je veux dire c'est le
parlement qui vote la loi monsieur la
souveraineté nationale appartient au
parlement
c'est pour ça que la réforme antillaise
n'a pas fonctionné et vous appliquer la
loi en fonction de la réalité une messe
j'ai deux amendements l'a1 qui vient
d'être votée
soutenu par nathalie bassir à
l'assemblée nationale qui va nous
permettre date de voter le star au
conseil régional il était votre
assemblée
la semaine dernière le schéma
d'aménagement il était votée semaine
dernière l'âge de classe donc là c'est
bien c'est bien une exception par
rapport la loi des français absolument
c'est même une exception rapport aux
antilles est alors expliquez nous
pourquoi est ce que vous voulez d'un
côté qu'il n'y a pas d'exception et de
l'autre vous voudrez bien qu'ils en
oublient vous ne voyez pas le creuset là
la france est une république indivisible
laïque son organisation décentralisée
c'est l'article 1 6 l et indivisible on
va te falloir marché forain de saint
andré
tantôt aux antilles tantôt à mafate la
loi ce vote à l'assemblée nationale
à paris et au sénat à paris mais cette
loi elle est pas uniforme
sl ce s'appliquera en fonction des
caractéristiques particulières de chaque
dom voilà c'est ce que l'hôtel
particulier le logement est particulier
aux dom la tv en particulier le droit
d'accise sur l'europe en particulier la
tva non perçue récupérable et
particuliers on est d'accord que la tva
est pratique de l'article 73 tel qu'il
est actuellement et qui s'applique dans
les autre débat qui n'a pas de sens cet
article 73 qui s'applique dans les
autres départements ne permet pas de
faire tout et n'importe quoi ce sont
bien les locaux qui choisissent de
d'adapter ou pas est sous contrôle du
conseil constitutionnel une loi
organique donc de toute façon il ya
beaucoup de garanties de ce que vous
venez de dire est faux excusez moi je le
dis les élus martiniquais guadeloupéens
guyanais
quand ils ont vu ils veulent avoir une
adaptation ils ont un champ très limitée
voilà c'est ce que je veux dire c'est
très compliqué très limité mais c'est
pas le conseil fonctionnel
quand ils ont envie d'adapter par
exemple en matière de transport alors
qu'il suffit de faire un amendement à
l'assemblée nationale eux ils lèvent le
doigt
il dit monsieur le premier ministre et
on m'a fait une délibération conseil
régional est ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour qu'on adapte en matière de
transport le premier ministre l'a dit
oui ils prennent une délibération le
parlement les habilitent il faut leur
adaptation qui va être encore corrigé
accepter ou pas par le gouvernement
pourquoi passer par ma fat pour aller à
saint pierre alors qu'il ya la route des
tamarins
moi je prends la route des tamarins
l'existence ou non de votre ligne et non
pêcheurs
non les histoires de mon amie léa
empêche circuit parce que moi quand j'ai
fait l'amendement sur le sahara et la
madame bâ ciel défendu à l'assemblée
nationale dans l'affluence ans oui c'est
toujours possible ça direct quand il le
faut peu le font par métaux le faire ils
peuvent le faire mais comme ils ont pris
le chemin de sentiers de mafate
ils sont coincés dedans il ya des
éboulis partout vous pensez que les élus
réunionnais sont pas responsables qui
sont pas à la hauteur que les
réunionnais sont pas capables de prendre
des décisions le cas n'est pas le sujet
pourquoi la réunion un département
français d'outre-mer le plus développé
parce que nous respectons la loi
pourquoi la réunion est le département
français le plus
le p parce que nous respectons les
règlements communautaires pourquoi la
réunion est le département français
d'outre-mer qui fait le plus
d'adaptations là le fit la
défiscalisation du logement social c'est
amendement virapoullé la défiscalisation
86 amendement virapoullé la tva non
perçue récupérable
j'ai fait rapport dessus l'adaptation
parlement oui l'adaptation en huit sous
guéi à la cuisine non clair beaucoup de
parlementaires veulent faire évoluer
cette situation david lorion proposer
une formulation qui permet d'empêcher la
création de la collectivité unique mais
qui autorise quand même des alliés des
adaptations en dehors du champ de
compétence de la région et du
département il faudrait que tous les
parlementaires soient d'accord sur cette
ligne vous vous n'êtes pas d'accord
ces parlementaires maison d'accord mais
les apparentés sont pas d'accord non
plus ça vous rassure de savoir qu'ils
sont pas tous d'accord
non ils sont pas d'accord pourquoi parce
que cet amendement n'apporte rien au
débat dans la vie ont choisi par le feu
et l'eau vous comprenez que
symboliquement ce que ça dit cet
amendement c'est les outre-mers peut
faire quelque chose mais la réunion nous
on veut pas le faire parce que on n'a
pas envie de mettre le doigt là parce
qu'on veut aller plus loin parce qu'on a
des ambitions plus grandes
c'est parce qu'on veut attirer je vous
donne un exemple aujourd'hui je discute
avec les multinationales qui vont
investir sur bois rouge toutes m'ont dit
on viendra investir sur la réunion parce
que la réunion stable institutionnels me
faisait peur que quelqu'un déstabilise
mais si on se met à bricoler dans la
législation comme aux antilles pourquoi
ils vont présenter pourquoi ils vont
plus pour right it
pourquoi les ceux qui ont beaucoup de
sociétés aux antilles viennent investir
à la réunion parce que la stabilité
c'est la clé de la confiance et la
confiance est la clé de l'investissement
et l'investissement c'est la clé de la
production et la production c'est la clé
de l'emploi
tout simplement jean-pierre plus vous
avez été débouté la semaine dernière par
le très bien administratives dans le
dossier qui vous oppose aux syndicats
sydney qui a signé avec il nous reste un
contrat pour le traitement stockage d
enfouissement la valorisation des
déchets collectés donc sur les
territoires la cinor et la cirest
qu'est ce que vous reprochez à ce
contrat on va faire le point après sur
la suite des événements mais mais
simplement moi je vais vous dire cherry
a continué j'ai rien contre une nouvelle
et encore moins contre le tribunal
administratif dont je respecte les
décisions
une chose est sûre je suis un élu local
on m'a appris que lorsqu'on dépasse 25
mille euros il faut faire un appel
d'offres mais là on n'a pas fait de
publicité qu'on n'a pas fait un appel
d'offres pour un marché
écoutez bien les entrepreneurs les
artisans 243 millions d'euros 1,4
milliard mais parce que le sydney
considèrent qu'ils s'étaient déjà
tributaire de ce marché là et que
c'était finalement signer considèrent
qu'ils ont un arrêté préfectoral est un
avantage technique
moi je considère pas alors le truc a
rendu sa décision le conseil d'état a
été saisi sur le premier refus du
théâtre nous verrons ce que dira le
conseil d'état nous sommes dans un état
de droit
les juges sont là pour dire la loi et
nous nous sommes là pour respecter le
jugement au fond qu'est-ce qui vous gêne
dans ce contrat
ben ce qui n'est pas une publicité c'est
que moi je suis membre de la commission
d'appel d'offres j'ai pas lu le contrat
contrairement à ce qu'a dit le th je
n'ai pas lu le contraint et le thé à n'a
pas le contrat non plus d'un contrat
dans les mentions sont biffés au feutre
on peut pas le lire et troisièmement
dans ce qui me gêne c'est que siné n'a
pas les moyens de d'utiliser le csr sert
ce combustible sur la récupération qui
régit et puis je vais dire une chose
contribuables écoutez moi bien que vous
habitiez depuis cette nuit jusqu'à
sainte rose cette affaire vous intéresse
moi j'ai été élu pour défendre vos
intérêts avec le président s'ils ne
s'étaient mis d'accord sur jeudi est là
là et c'est écrit dans les délibérations
on s'était mis d'accord pour faire une
cmox tm c'est ma objet unique une simple
société du climat avec avec 51 %
d'actions pour nous ceux ci restent
cinor et 49 pour celui qui aurait eu
l'appel d'offres mais comme ils ont pris
une autre procédure
c'est suez innove s qui a un tout temps
toutes les cartes en main nous on aura
une seule cas c'est payer l'addition
je dis aux contribuables suivez bien mon
combat c'est pour vous que je le mène
parce que quand vous verrez l'addition
tomber d'ici 4-5 ans vous allez crier et
ça sera trop tard et la sphère de deux
gros
sous on ne voit ça se compte en dizaines
en vous l'avais dit en dizaines de
millions d'euros
vous avez peur que des malversations non
moi je ne soupçonne pas ni mes collègues
ni les sociétés les juges sont là pour
faire leur travail
moi je suis là pour défendre la loi
c'est mon interprétation de la loi de
dire que cette procédure n'est pas légal
le conseil d'état dira ce qu'il a à dire
y apprend l'appliquera décision du
conseil d'état tranquillement comme on
appliquera le vote du parlement
je voulais dire une chose aussi je suis
rassuré pourquoi parce que dans la
réforme constitutionnelle il faut que la
loi votée à l'assemblée soit à la
virgule près la même que celle qui sera
voté au sénat l'assemblée ne l'emportent
pas sur le sénat dans le cadre de la
constitution
donc le débat reste ouvert et c'est le
bon sens qui l'emportera concrètement
pour cette histoire de déchets le
président de la région didier robert
sanglants entre s'est déclaré opposé ou
aux uv aux unités de valorisation sont
inégales énergétique voilà qui sont
maintenant de toute façon modeste au
niveau européen il préconise si j'ai
bien compris l'utilisation des centrales
à charbon d'albion à pour justement
brûler ses ces combustibles
ces déchets résiduels après avoir
fortement très fortement augmenté le tri
en amont est ce que cette politique vous
semble correct mais je vais vous dire je
pense que actuellement on ne lit pas
assez la loi de transition énergétique
la loi de transition énergétique a été
voulu par madame royal elle est claire
d'abord le le citoyen la citoyenne doit
éviter d'avoir beaucoup de déchets
deuxièmement on doit pratiquer le tri à
la maison aussi ça se fait dans beaucoup
de pays
troisièmement quand les déchets arrivent
à la station de traitement c'est là que
passe le tri entre les matières
fermentiscibles et les matières
recyclables papier le plastique les
piles etc
une fois qu'on a fait le tri et qu'on a
mis en place ce qui va être la grande
vertu du 21e siècle l'économie
circulaire afin de pomper les richesses
de la terre à partir du mois de
septembre on pompe la richesse de
l'année d'après c'est ce qu'on fait on
consomme
crédit bnc joie la terre met en colère
elle est déjà mère donc on trie on
recycle et réutilise il ya soit un vrai
bon reportage sur france 24 sur renault
mais renault dit il ya 35 % de matières
recyclées dans les voitures actuelles
c'est ce qu'il faut faire et après il
n'a pas la matière fermentiscibles
aujourd'hui on en fait du combustible
solide de récupération c'est ce que fait
veut faire une nouvelle
à juste titre et après on l'envoie
didier robert chez al biomasse moi je
voulais dans le projet le procédé qui a
été mis en place par notre bureau
d'études ne voulait construire une usine
pour faire de l'énergie nous même gagné
une marge financière qu'on aurait rendu
aux contribuables qui payent trop cher à
aujourd'hui l'eau les déchets que
c'était donc le process qui consiste à
envoyer chez al biomet un process légal
ce qui n'est pas légal dans la sphère de
suez c'est qu'il n'y a pas de thriasos
et là c'est considéré comme un tri
mécano biologique et le tmb n'est pas
légal nous verrons ce que dira un
conseil d'état trois arrêts de cour
administrative d'appel de bordeaux et de
lyon ont condamné les arrêtés
préfectoraux qui validait les tmb donc
on verra s'est arrêté du préfet actuel
résiste à l'analyse des hauts magistrats
affaire à suivre donc on va parler
environnement encore avec ce projet de
carrière à dioré sur votre territoire de
saint-andré une carrière qui doit
alimenter normalement le chantier de la
nouvelle route du littoral on sait que
ce chantier a besoin de roches massives
pour construire pour construire la
partie digues et que le chantier risque
éventuellement d'être un peu en panne
faute de faute faute de ressasser et
pourtant cette carrière n'ouvre pas
expliqué louise pascual esp quand je
suis arrivée à la mairie en mars 2014
j'ai trouvé un dossier de d'ouverture
d'une carrière à dioré qui avait été
initié par mon prédécesseur un show
photo cave estimé h était d'ailleurs
qu'il fallait faire une carrière a duré
pour
alimenter la route du littoral j'avais
deux positions dire ça c'est un projet
de mon adversaire j'ai le bloc ou bien
alors écoutez ce que vous avez dit le
préfet fait un pig un projet d'intérêt
général avec la callas durée c'est ce
que nous avons fait et nous allons voter
le pig le préfet a pris un arrêté est
aujourd'hui la carrière est un état
d'ouvrir ce moment sauf que à force de
charger la barque
j'ai les autorités de l'état ont fait
couler le bateau ils ont mis dans le
projet de modification du schéma
départemental des carrières qui conforme
aux salles et aux cnvm et tout ça ils
ont rajouté durée de faux je croise un
talent et puis là bim du trou et
nathalie baye les gars on dit ça c'est
une légère modification
c'est une grosse donc ça ce schéma
départemental ition révision du monde
par le trio de bordeaux mais c'est pas
ce qui a empêché que tu aurais aussi du
coup au jour d'aujourd'hui la grâce ne
durait n'a plus de base légale ce qui a
empêché avant que tony à 2 pourquoi
parce que lui aussi son entreprise comme
des trucs préfet a pris l'arrêté
préfectoral on n'a pas ouvert mais c'est
une bataille de titans entre un
groupement est une entreprise
l'entreprise est gérée avec carrière la
convention de chantage et les
propriétaires et le groupement qui
voulez le beurre et l'argent du beurre
trouvé que légal était trop cher il a
fait capoter
mais nous nous sommes pour rien là
dedans nous on a fait ce qu'il fallait
parce que la route du littoral est vital
regarder tous les matins à voter h tiens
je l'avais dit on dans des missions vous
êtes d'avoir misé mais on le sait donc
on fait avec on va il ya beaucoup de
questions on va on va écouter un peu de
musique comme intermède musical que
c'est vous qui l'avez choisi comme comme
chaque invité aux demandes de choisir
une musique jean paul virapoullé vous
avez choisi la vie en rose pas la
version chantée par edith piaf mais
celle joué à la trompette par l'immense
police un instant
[Musique]
m
ce domaine
ainsi hier un bleu
[Musique]
elle a par hasard
and when you speak white si tout n était
absent
[Musique]
à
la vie en rose chanté par louis
armstrong choisi par notre invité jean
paul virapoullé pourquoi ce choix
on doit lui donner parce qu'ils ont
compris avec mes défauts mes qualités
que j'aime la réunion j'aime cette
population et quand j'écoute doug
armstrong qui clame blé mon enfance avec
django reinhardt avec tous les grands du
jazz
j'ai eu le bonheur de l'entendre au
palais de la méditerranée j'avais c1
lille à lille dans à nice et il m'a
marqué et aujourd'hui c'est le 10 juin
vous m'avez invité 10 juin j'ai fait un
clin d'oeil réunir dix ans c'est vrai la
vie n'est pas rose pour tout le monde
mais on a tellement d'atouts de notre
jeu allons mettre de côté nos plaintes
permanente allons allons avoir confiance
en nous allons saisir cette vie et tout
ce que l'état les collectivités l'europe
met à notre disposition
j'étais dans un pays africain ya pas
longtemps les gens vivent avec 3 euros
par jour
il travaille poids 100 euros par mois
j'ai dit quand vous êtes malade quand
vous faites à des monsieur qu'on est
malade on meurt j'ai dit vous n'allez
pas à l'hôpital et d'ici mais c'est
pareil
qu'on aille à l'hôpital où qu'on aille
pas c'est pareil alors nous réunionnais
c'est vrai qu'on a encore des problèmes
mais toute façon là où il ya la vie à
des problèmes mais à l'on travaille
ensemble on relève ce pays et dans
quelques semaines je vous présenterai le
projet de l'éco technopole de bois rouge
qui va révolutionner l'économie de cette
île nous en avons les moyens
alors va pour venir pour revenir
justement au développement économique
gens préfèrent appeler vous êtes plus
parlementaire mais vous l'avez été très
longtemps et la scène et on l'a vu dans
le cas de la réforme constitutionnelle
vous êtes toujours très actif vous
arpentez les couloirs du sénat de
l'assemblée
on vous connaît là-bas vous êtes avec
les dossiers sous le bras
qu'est-ce que vous avez aujourd'hui de
ce que contient le fameux livre bleu aux
canes jardin
livre au mieux d outre mer cannes jardin
de remettre au président de la
république le 28 juin qu'est ce que la
caisse qui contient et qui concerne la
réunion et que vous pouvez me dire
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire une chose
les assises de l'outre-mer comme tout
les assises comme tous les rapports
c'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga de faut que
les réunionnais comprennent que c'est
pas paris qui décide pour nous livre le
livre est allé viol
c'est la blague tout ça c'est bien qu'il
ya une réflexion c'est bien qu'ils aient
quelques écrits mais je prends le projet
de les côtés de nos portes
ça veut dire ça veut dire qui aura rien
dedans non ça veut dire qu'il y aura des
idées directrices monsieur thierry
bert's a dit lui-même dans le journal de
l'île que j'ai lu il le dit lui-même il
y aura sept analystes
mais tout ne s'arrête pas au livre bleu
et puisque vous parlez de livre bleu je
voudrais vous dire pourquoi j'ai mis
cette chanson de choisi cette chanson
jouée amstrong la vie en rose c'est
parce que l'avenir de là réunion va se
dessiner dans l'océan indien
l'océan indien va nous amener l'océanic
profonde à 5 degrés au moment où je vous
parle monsieur le dantec
je travaille main dans la main avec la
plus grosse société navale pour que
l'énergie thermique des mers soit
brevetée à bois rouge
c'est une révolution dans le domaine de
l'énergie je travaille avec la cosmetic
valley pour que les grands cosméticienne
français viennent utiliser cette eau
pour faire des produits construction
éthiques
la cosmétique est le deuxième produit
d'exportation de la france 46 milliards
155 mille emplois je travaille
aujourd'hui avec le groupe ionis à paris
qui viendra en septembre ouvrir sup
biotech à la réunion parce que la
biotechnologie sera pour les jeunes qui
montent ce qu'a été la machine à vapeur
pour moi etc
je veux dire par là que nous avons
confiance en l'avenir parce que cette
population métisse elle a beaucoup de
talent cette population métisse elle
vient de tous les continents l'europe
lui apporter moyens la région le
département les communes l'état apporté
moyen assez pleuré allons voir la vie
différemment à l'on relève le défi du
développement des biotechnologies du
développement numérique du développement
des énergies renouvelables du
développement de la réunion porte
maritime de l'europe est une grande
multinationale est en train de discuter
avec nous pour faire de la réunion la
station-service du globe du gaz naturel
liquide pour les bateaux qui passent
haut la réunion jean paul virapoullé je
peux vous interrompre médicinales aussi
la vôtre dans votre élan mais mais on
n'est pas au meeting de campagne là
aujourd'hui maman va tout dans meeting
je vois pas ce que vous pouvez nous dire
là aujourd'hui il va se passer quoi
précisément à quelle date est ce que il
va y avoir des embauches est ce qu'il va
y avoir des constructions ben oui mais
on peut vous le dire on peut vous dire
déjà que aujourd'hui avec le
développement des entreprises à la
réunion
et vous avez vu dernièrement monsieur
fayolle est venu signer que le président
de région
un mode de crédit à 1,50 pour 185
millions pour les entreprises puissent
emprunter et se développe dans les
grands projets que vous avez mon sur les
grands projets créés mais je vous dis un
calendrier où est-ce qu'on aurait encore
au sort en septembre 2018
donc ça biotech ckoi précisé biotech
c'est lui a cité privé qui travaille
avec epitech dans le groupe ionis à
paris et qui forme les ingénieurs en
biotechnologie vous avez vu quelques
épis tech on va former en forme dégradée
ingénieurs dans le numérique
maintenant je forme les ingénieurs de la
biotechnologique sur la technologie de
de ce siècle
deuxièmement vendredi ce vendredi la
semaine prochaine je serai chez monsieur
hulot
son directeur général ce directeur
général adjoint de monsieur le cône qui
étaient ici pour leur présenter et
probablement avec le président de région
qui m'a dit qui va me le confirmer ses
dires bien viendra avec nous on sera
ensemble plutôt pour présenter le projet
d'énergie renouvelable à partir de la
mer au stade de projet alors les
quartiers des choses tackels et je suis
déterminé ce qui est des premiers ce qui
est bien trouvée dans l'appel à projets
national qui va être fait si on ne
s'attendrait retenue dans l'appel à
projets le groupe energy navale qui
était l'ancien dcns un des premiers
groupes français qui fond sous marin
ils vont pouvoir être le fer de lance
pour participer à ce projet d'énergie
renouvelable qui est unique en france
nous voudrions que le brevet de ces
usines qui vont se multiplier dans le
monde après soit réunionnais parce que
on se souvient que voilà deux grands
projets d'exploration dans l'eau potable
d'un grand port a laissé ce sera pour
l'instant on voir paul est ainsi on a
fait trois études qui ont conclu à la
faisabilité la dernière arrive fin juin
pour l'instant on l'a quand même si on
sait que des études de la réalisation
est parfois un grand parc
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui monsieur
dantec votre question intéressante ce
que nous faisons nous mettons ces trois
rails en place via le rail de l'étude
via le rail des partenariats avec les
multinationales et il ya le rail
européen avec le programme jasper et
monsieur fayolle a été d'un grand
recours celle remercier ici puisque
quand il est venu à la réunion et qui
m'a été présenté par le président de
région il adopter tout de suite le
projet de l'éco technopole de bois rouge
et ses services travaillent avec nous
mais dans la main et d'ici un mois
oui les dates on va aller faire agréer
le projet là bas et une fois qu'il sera
gré nous allons participer à l'appel à
projet autoroute de la mer
les grands ports européens les chinois
font créé la route de la soie
nous on veut être dans le domaine des
ports sur la route de grand pan européen
les prochaines échéances électorales ce
sont les européennes oui dans un an
vous parlez souvent de l'europe c'est un
sujet que je connais bien qu'il joue pas
seulement européenne la première il y
aura pas de circonscription spécifiques
à l'outre-mer de regretter dommage c'est
une faute politique
c'est une fois de politique parce que
nos problèmes sont différents
déjà être parlementer affront c'est dans
ce capharnaüm à strasbourg c'est pas
facile
si en plus il n'ya pas des représentants
de régions éloignées mais qui va parler
nous le temps nous ne sommes pas des
régions françaises
un institut personae nous sommes les
régions françaises ultrapériphériques
avec un statut particulier que j'ai fait
adopter à l'époque par monsieur
mitterrand quand il était président on
avec la complicité de michel rocard
donc je trouve aujourd'hui que c'est une
injustice une faute politique une grave
erreur d'avoir pas dix bombes et les
listes front national
mais dans les dix premiers il y aura
représentant de l'outre-mer à chaque
partie peut le faire mais ça à chaque
partie peut le faire mais les égoïsmes
des parties ou savez si j'ai fait 1 48
ans demande à ce jour c'est pas grâce
aux partis politiques là c'est grâce aux
saint-andré nîmes pablo réunionnais
ensuite le succès des eurosceptiques en
europe sociale aragon lors des dernières
élections présidentielles montre on va
dire pour le moins une défiance
vis-à-vis de de france et l'europe à ce
que ça vous encore vous n'avez pas de
colonne s'inquiète pour l'avenir de là
réunion
on voit qu'il a dit la réunion parce que
la réunion si réussie du grand projet je
vous ai dit va devenir une base de
l'europe mais ce qui est grave c'est que
l'europe ça forme un tout ou bien
l'europe se solidifie où l'europe
éclater si l'europe éclater la dimension
nationale des pays ne leur permet plus
de dominer le monde d'exister dans le
monde et on va avoir un basculement à
l'ouest avec les états unis vivent au
temple comme ils peuvent avec les chefs
d'état qui rend l'amérique latine
morcelé par des régimes extravagant et
puis nous aurons une puissance à l'est
l'asie la chine laine qui vont dominer
le monde
l'avenir du monde va se jouer sur la fin
de ce siècle plus tôt en asie qu'en
europe pour exister
je vous dis une phrase d'un homme
célèbre connu et performances et jacques
delors nous sommes allés le rencontrer à
l'époque avec magie sud à a1 boxait la
commission et à la question que je lui
ai posé
monsieur le président de la commission
il a fait beaucoup pour nous un pour le
paquet de l'or pour les rup c'est
quelque chose et j'ai dit monsieur le
président l'europe pour quoi faire
il m'a dit on n'a pas le choix on fait
l'europe où on disparaît on en est là
aujourd'hui
malheureusement les égoïsmes nationaux
tous extrémisme de droite et d'extrême
gauche
et ces extrémismes en faire éclater le
berceau de la paix de la liberté et du
progrès que le roi quand le patron des
républicains laurent wauquiez
fait un tract qui dit la france de
rester la france mais ça cesse le grand
politicien local
campagnard mais la france reste la
france lorsqu'elle devient le fer de
lance de la construction européenne
la france reste la france quand de
gaulle prend son stylo et syna rome le
traité de rome avec adenauer mais la
france reste la france aussi quand de
gaulle prend son stylo mais dans sa
poche et se lève et ne signe pas le
traité parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
quotas ban pour les antilles et donc la
france elle existe
lorsqu'elle est pose sa vision avec les
autres états européens la france isolée
elle n'existe pas ça dit quelque chose
de l'état de la droite française et
peut-être de la droite réunionnaise
aussi ce qui se passe à la direction des
républicains avec donc laurent wauquiez
qui vient de virer virginie calmels sa
numéro de sa mère n'était pas d'accord
avec ce tract qui disait qu'elle est que
la ligne de le révoquer est beaucoup
trop projet celle du rassemblement
national nouveau nom du front national
bah écoutez je vais vous citer sarkozy
nous c'est que j'ai eu des différends
avec lui mais la raison idy unis c'est
difficile de gagner des unis on est sûr
de perdre c'est ce qui est en train de
se préparer
pourquoi parce que chacun regarde son
nombril l'europe c'est pas son nombril
est ce que va faire deux droites
irréconciliables entre une qui on en est
à chercher qui va chasser sur les terres
du front national qualif c'est des
petits qualif ça chacun veut être calife
à la place du calife
vous savez quand je me rappelle encore
lorsque on a fait les traiter enfin
excusez moi mais on parle de questions
de fond c'est pas simplement une
histoire d'ego le discours est
radicalement différent trains centre
droit et est ce qu'une mère allait
décider radicalement ce grand promoteur
et ce qui est radicalement différent sur
le fond parce qu'on n'est pas d'accord
sur le fond ou est ce qu'on n'est pas
d'accord sur le fond ou en secret à des
accords sur le fond pour créer sa propre
écurie
je crois plutôt à deuxième hypothèse
vous croyez que c'est réconciliables
donc la lie j'espère en jouer
réconciliables et toute façon dans
l'état où se trouve la droite
à mon avis il y aura une troisième force
qui va naître est ce que finalement
aujourd'hui c'est pas emmanuel macron
qui représente le centre droit même
manuel marquez a lancé un défi
il ya un an étaient pas il ya deux ans
n'était pas connue aujourd'hui les
présidents
il fait des réformes que personne ne
sait faire il les fait on verra les
résultats ci réussit il sera réélu s'il
échoue le peuple décidera mais une chose
est sûre ce que la france ne peut pas
rester en piste et dans ses certitudes
qui sont dit si vous êtes un autre six
accusés plutôt satisfait je suis
interrogatif
et comme j'aime tellement la mère patrie
je me dis j'espère que ce pays va
réussir et qu'on l'a reconnu soit pas 12
est ce qu'il ya dans ce que fait
aujourd'hui dans ce que fait aujourd'hui
le maquereau et le ski vous qui vous
vont pas moi ce qui me choque c'est les
paroles plus que les actes deuxièmement
je pense que on aurait pu mettre un
point tva est pas toucher à la retraite
des petites retraites
je pense qu on aurait pu aussi relancer
un peu plus la croissance
pour avoir plus de richesses et plus
d'emploi m'enfin c'est lui le patron
c'est lui le président c'est lui qui
prend les risques
nous nous sommes là pour accompagner la
réussite de l'état parce que l'état
français
c'est quand même là le fer de lance du